[Musique]
et si tu danses c'est un spectacle à
mi-chemin entre théâtre et danse qui
s'inspire du petit pousser et bien avec
et si tu danses la chorégraphe Marion
Lévy et l'autrice Mariette Navaro
imagine le petit pousser devenu grand et
si tu danses c'est un spectacle tendre
et joyeux qui initie les plus petits à
l'invention à la création et permet au
plus grand de renouer avec les pouvoirs
de de
[Musique]
l'imagination le spectacle et situd Dan
sera proposé dans un cadre tout à fait
exceptionnel celui du château de de
Breteuil le fameux château des comptes
de pro deux représentations sont prévues
l'une à 11h et l'autre à 15h30 dans
l'une des belles bâtis du château dans
l'une des dépendances qui s'appelle
l'Orangerie
[Musique]
alors c'est la première fois en effet
que le théâtre de 5antan Eveline
programme un spectacle au château de
Breteuil euh c'est un spectacle qui
s'inscrit dans ce qu'on appelle le tsqy
embalade c'est une série de spectacle
itinérant de forme légère que nous
proposons dans des lieux non équipés
cette saison nous avons en tout neuf
spectacle TSC y embalade donc qui vont
sillonner l'ensemble du département des
ivelines ça représente près de 8000
spectateurs et cela touche plus d'une
près d'une trentaine de de communes
[Applaudissements]
ivelinoises les réservations sont
possibles sur le site du Théâtre he
théatresqy.org navette et proposé aux
spectateurs qui le souhaitent voilà
toutes les infopratiques sur le site les
enfants de moins de 5 ans ont une
gratuité bénéficient d'une gratuité et
à partir de 5 ans et pour tous le tarif
est de 12
€